oh life in Tel Aviv has mostly returned
to normal since October the 7th shops
restaurants businesses and schools have
reopened but speak to anyone here and
they'll tell you there's only one thing
on their Minds The Return of the nearly
240 captives held in Gaza as soon as
possible for us it's just one day and
well in the
48 day in in this world but for this
children every moment and every day that
he lives underground there in Gaza his
all dies so I just hope it will be one
day or less than one day because every
moment is important the ceasefire agreed
between Hamas and Israel was meant to
begin on Thursday morning and for much
of the day the reasons for the delay
remained unclear when you are making a
deal with Hamas you should not expect
everything to go by the plan and you
should expect uh
surprises but we are prepared for
it an emotional roller coaster is what
friends and relatives of the captives
have called it in what's become known as
hostage Square people talk and speculate
as they wait for further news tears and
prayers from the families of those held
captive hoping for their return sooner
rather than later and it's just behind
me over here that prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu in a public speech
Direct addressed those families saying
that his heart was with them and he'll
keep them updated on everything related
to the ceasefire deal Israel says it's
the military pressure that has paved the
way to this
ceasefire we're trying to connect the
goals of the war so that the ground
operation brings about the ability to
create the conditions for the release of
the abducted hostages we are not ending
the war we will continue until we are
victorious Israel also says that the
only way to bring back not just the
women and children but all of the
captives is to continue its war on Gaza
until Hamas is completely eliminated s
Al jazer Tel
Aviv make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer